oui bon moi je suis pleinement d'accord
il n'y a pas que là dessus avec brice
est depuis longtemps en matière de droit
d'asile
c'est très joli c'est un fonds de
commerce permanent médiatique pour la
gauche le droit d'asile ne doit pas être
touché le droit d'asile est une
tradition française et c'est la vérité
la france a dans le passé accueilli des
gens persécutés pour chasser dans leur
pays
et ça doit se maintenir sauf que le
droit d'asile qui était une valeur
fondatrice presque de la république est
devenue une valeur des tournées et que
progressivement les 10000 quinze mille
demandeurs d'asile que nous avions il ya
20 ans sont devenus 65000 et toutes
procédures confondues
nous acceptons chaque année sur les
65000 à peu près 14 à 15 mille personnes
comme réfugiés ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
cinquante mille personnes qui
n'obtiennent pas chaque année le droit
d'asile
en gros nous en raccompagnant cinq à dix
mille aux frontières ce qui veut dire
qu'au travers du droit d'asile
en réalité la france fabrique chaque
année 40 milles sans papiers voilà la
vérité alors la vérité elle est simple
c'est que le droit d'asile aujourd'hui
est devenue une filière des tournées de
l'immigration économique et c'est tout
le nombre de ceux qui réellement devrait
avoir l'asile de droit de tradition par
rapport à la tradition française n'est
pas de plus que du quart de ce que nous
avons en demande aujourd'hui
et quand on voit les décisions
européennes
l'acceptation par la france et brice le
disais tout à l'heure
bernard cazeneuve françois noël pendant
le débat au sénat
je lui dis combien vous allez en
accueillir au mois de juillet il me dit
pas plus de 9000 sur deux ans est un
engagement d'état déjà au mois de
septembre
françois hollande jeudi 24 milles mais
24 bits et sur la deuxième mouture est à
dire sur les cent vingt mille thales
était déjà 24000 plus les 9000 donc
33000 et puis quand on demande aux
autorités européennes
mais dites y'a écrit mécanisme permanent
de répartie
bon ça veut dire quoi eh ben ça veut
dire que les autorités allemandes que
les autorités européennes disent très
clairement qu'en réalité c'est si on y
arrive puisque certains états d'europe
de l'est y opposent
mais si on y arrive y aura une deuxième
répartition avant noël une troisième
répartition en 2016 et qu'en réalité
bien des autorités françaises
travaillent d'ores et déjà sur le fait
que nous ayons entre 70 et 90 mille
demandeurs supplémentaires pas demandeur
réfugiés supplémentaires dans les deux
ans ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'en réalité le droit
d'asile est totalement détournées ça
veut dire que l'étude fondatrice sur le
droit d'asile mais n'a plus de sens
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas la même
liste dans l'ensemble des pays européens
des pays sûrs nous n'avons pas les mêmes
conditions d'accès nous avons en france
soit disant voter un texte de réforme du
droit d'asile
c'est un texte vide parce qu'on dit
officiellement corps a confié les délais
d'étude mais il n'y a pas de sanction il
ya pas de moyens supplémentaires ce qui
veut dire qu'en réalité les demandes et
les études sur le droit d'asile sont
aussi longues d'autrefois avec les mêmes
allocations avec les mêmes droits et les
réfugiés qui viendraient ils auraient
droit à la fois au rsa à la cmu et à
l'ensemble des moyens d'intégration
quand monsieur sapin notre brave
ministre dit à la radio que le fait de
recevoir des dizaines de milliers de
réfugiés supplémentaires ne coûterait
que quelques millions c'est évidemment
galéjade
ça coûtera minimum 2 milliards sur
l'année 2016 s'ils sont entre 50 et 70
milles donc il faut qu'on sache qu est
ce que ça veut dire
avec quels moyens il n'y a plus une
place en cada il n'y a plus une place
dans les hébergements d'urgence
il n'y a plus une place sur l'ensemble
de ce que serait fut plus tard la
métropole ile de france
y a plus une place dans les hôtels une
étoile parce que toutes les places sont
réquisitionnés pour les demandeurs
d'asile
alors quand on dit on va recevoir 50
villes probablement dans les 18 mois
ouais ce qu'on les place ou est ce qu'on
les accueille
parce que la traduction du droit d'asile
c'est aussi une tradition d'un accueil
digne de ce nom et d'une intégration à
la nation française digne de ce nom
ça n'est pas faire du canton
natif ça n'est pas ne pas mettre en
place aussi les moyens d'intégrer bien
ce qu'ils méritent
le statut de réfugié alors ne détournons
pas le statut de réfugié ne détournons
pas le droit d'asile en lui-même et
faisons en sorte de refuser ce qui est
aujourd'hui de l'immigration économique
merci roger